note positive jeudi un bon ben voilà on
va garder ça pour l'intro as très bien
aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur vannes et
charges était sorti à 1 en alpha et qui
a subi de nombreuses mises à jour
normalement si la version finale avec
tout ce qu'il faut pour avoir peur parce
qu'on n'aime pas oula oula font mal aux
yeux alors on voit mieux adacore objets
tôt qu'elle joue comme ça comme une
vieille merde alors à wsd to move machin
to look web comme dans dans 80 mille
pour cent des jeunes à une lampe ou quoi
que ce soit parce que c'est là bien
sombre là-bas et ben on va prendre ça à
on peut pas en comme c'est dommage
ok gauche ou droite droitier lumière
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour trouver
une sortie je suppose un oui normalement
compte en fait dans un cachot envie de
sortir donc je pense qu'il faut qu'ils
trouvent une sortie au cas j'ai peur de
lumière [ __ ] une page à faut trouver
des pages est ce que tu as déjà regardé
dans le water peuple chambre
eh ben on va on va la trouver water
pomme chambre j'ai très bien quoi y'a un
truc noir comme ça au bout c'est que
c'est à dire qui est un monstre qui va
paraître qui va sortir une nulle part
inquiet nous accrocher le bras ou la
tête et cette première rencontre avec le
monstre est toujours très délicate à ce
que je disais justement hole ben voilà
fallait aller à gauche allait retourner
au point de départ
non non objection interdiction noyade et
des bruits mais [ __ ] mais arrêtez
bordel mais attends mais non mais oui
mais c'est ça la particularité du jeu je
les lui en plus c'est que que le décor
est générée aléatoirement ce qui est
génial pour te perdre bien comme il faut
aux n'explose pas jeunes là on part est
avec moi c'est le top ok c'est la
poussière bon attend le cas ça va quand
même un outil une page est apparue et
bordel d'où viennent ces gros trous dans
les murs fils mais je ne sais pas j'ai
pas vu deux trous dans les murs jusqu'à
présent juste vu des grilles hockey des
grilles que je ne vais plus touchées
wattens bah voilà water pomme c'est par
là c'est ça lui à tort comme ça alors on
va dégager
j'ai pas envie d'aller au water pas
bloqué tu me dis poche doit aller [ __ ]
j'suis water pas de son gars terme et
c'est à dire il ya un truc un élément
qui intervient sans déconner est ce qu
est ce qu il est relié à mon micro suis
sûr qu'il attend en position foetale
dans un coin et que nous sommes un
gaouaoui alors on l'attend ce pas la
même écriture déjà je pense que j'ai vu
quelque chose dans ces tunnels
il ressemble à un rat géant ou un oiseau
géant quelque chose d'étrange inc ok
merci du conseil mais je m'en fous je
veux continuer à faire là bas tu ne
nuira pas en erreur au maire barrage et
ont un oiseau géant il tient pas dans ce
cas ce qu'annonce et moyens du tout non
mais il veut main durant dix ans ça se
trouve tout et le branchement tout de
suite donc le jeu se dire non rebelle va
gagner oh merde c'est quoi ça m
aird il voulait juste bd ok bah je m'en
vais merci en catastrophe un panneau
[ __ ] j'ai eu un truc dans le bidon
sans déconner tu as était le screamer
fais quoi j'ai vu des petites fesses au
loin j'ai eu peur c'est que c'est que ce
à quoi regarder comme on le voit bien
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça c'est
pas du tout aramon gard à où ils se
déplacent de manière très sensuelle mais
il est dégueulasse donc s'appelle tous
ensemble alors moi je me casse un salut
ok il va me manquer c'est sûr et j'ai
pas vu de trou géant dans le mur là
quelqu'un parle et roger ans j'aimerais
bien voir mon furent par un [ __ ] de
trou géant au trou géant du mur il
suffisait de et pourquoi être une trou
géant dans le mur bassar agir alors mon
gars il a creusé dans le mur
tranquillement pour faire son petit
terrier qui est sûr c'est que c'est vrai
qu'on attendait et d'intestins de
baleines kouao mais mais mais c'est pire
car là bien mais comment tu veux gagner
ce jeu il faut tout miser sur la chance
mon gas toho par exemple là là j'aurais
perdu 1000 euros là si j'avais joué
quelque chose et français je peux passer
délicatement dans son dos très
discrètement comme ça pourquoi pourquoi
il me fait ça qu'est ce qui me fait
faire mon game étouffe à distance oh non
qu'est ce qu'il fait [ __ ] les mecs
efficace quoi attend ce mec adsl de
karaté d'experts non c'est sûr et c'est
pas branché à quelque chose
alors pourquoi je prends pas ça pour
éclairer afin de mettre devant moi ce
serait magnifique gauche non droit de
cette fois je ne me ferai pas avoir
reviennent pas de l'autre côté et a
qu'un seul radio il ya plusieurs rats
géants [ __ ] qu'est ce que c'est on ne
sait pas à ça on nous le dit pas à ça
faut que je fasse droite droite pour
atteindre la page à page qui ne sert à
rien à part me dire je crois que c'est
anwar au géant à mes jeux suis pas sûr
alors de toutes obédiences certainement
te casser le cou mais j'espère que mon
message tu auras et des hatoyama un truc
là follow the pips c'est vrai qu'un mec
et des ah bah voilà
et tu as dit qu'on n'aurait jamais
besoin de ses papiers à attend avec fait
une blague il est en train à nos
ingénieurs à mort quoi ton calme toi je
ne mourrai pas dans ses couloirs sombres
je mourrai dans ses couloirs sombres
qu'est-ce qui fait contre les murs plus
tard c'est ça qui fait que nos corps a
fait un mélange de salive et de sang ça
donne envie qu'ils ont avec lequel
indique le chemin et arrête de faire
mais il ya un truc
pourquoi ça peut être tout le temps à
côté de moi mais des milliers de mètres
de celui d'un tube qui pète au dessus de
moi un sérieux ayhan flèche jaune vert
là bas on va suivre les flèches jaunes
follow the pines
ouais souffler
ech han moi aussi ça me vient odier
houllier sais pas si tu perds tu sais
que ça eux s'ils arrivent je mens glossy
kind of ice j'appuie sur f si je vois je
vous jure je le doigt sur [ __ ] mais
c'était pour effet papier / f on avait
trouvé la salle d eau dans lequel il y
avait des glo stick
ah oui oh oui à puce et les casseurs
soient un peu de bien merci merci je
suis pas sur l'âge et la radio et tu as
dit qu'on aurait jamais besoin c'est pas
toi tu m'as déjà fait la blague tout à
l'heure en tout cas salut salut la
chance inouïe oui alors eux cf
j'appuie sur f à ta 1 pouces mon gars tu
mets pas d'épave tu mets des coups de
pouce toi on ferme les yeux sur ce que
je vais dire il n'y a pas de problème on
sent que l'effort des développeurs a été
essentiellement sur la croate
j'espère au moins que monsieur rats
géants aux rappeurs ou en othe poussins
c'est pour nous être utile c'est bon on
est sauvé pas tant que ça tout droit à
gauche ou à droite
waouh ah merde merde mais du coup mes
quatre techniques de mer du coup je suis
plus d'où je viens et comme par hasard
annoncé bout d'une note ligne dans le
rail
c'est quoi ça je sais pas ce que c'est
france à j'ai un trousseau de clés c'est
pas la sortie non non non non non non je
vais me tuer bon bien sûr on trouve pas
on reviendra ici qu'est ce que c'est que
ça qu'est ce que c'est toi c'est toi tu
est jalouse t jalouse de structurer ces
objets dans la main et bâtons ceci est
le pire truc que tu peux faire dans un
jeu de mains [ __ ] à revenir au point
de départ sans déconner ah oui note
elles sont tellement utile oh oh oh nous
a fait peur ils voulaient pas cool is il
n'aime pas la lecture quoi j'espère que
tu pourras trouver mes clés j'espère que
tu verras ce message indique j'ai ton
message était clé maintenant tu
m'indique juste à porte d'entrée et on
va devenir meilleur ami phil meilleur
ami vraiment je t'emmènerai à dans ma
vie d'un gonflables et tout fera la fête
et tout dans la piscine gonflable
je te présenterait même ma poupée
gonflable bon ça va les délires
gonflables savoir on y arrivera croyez
moi même si tout est fluide que c'est de
l'autre côté abbas et parce que c'est de
l'autre côté il ya un plan c'est très
gentil et un plan que je comprends
parfaitement
c'est l'entrée on est de retour à
l'entrée au nom
ah ah je suis dégoûté on avait tout ce
qu'il fallait [ __ ] des testicules jahr
der on avait des clés ne manquait juste
la sortie je n'abandonnerai jamais fait
pas continuer à taguées sur les murs
l'attend plus j'aimais bien son travail
j'aimais bien j'ai même acheté un
tableau alors poupe et il continue pas
c'est un super artiste quoi ils gâchent
son talent là à faire des n'importe quoi
là haut
voilà on l'activé n'ont reculé à lebrun
au [ __ ] j'ai eu peur non ça c'est raté
un sas et jeu mais je vous le dis je
vous dis puisque d'habitude j'ai
beaucoup d'affinités avec les tuyaux ok
ok on l'a vu un homme s'appuyer les
coudes contre le mur af pour trouver la
sortie là haut ou d'accord ok même sur
la tour n'a pas les clefs [ __ ] mais
cette façon ça va se concrétiser par un
dîner romantique avec leur âge et non
mais ça je vous le dis je vous le dis je
en train de dire que ça soit la sortie
c'était le trou en fait j'ai négligé la
menor mais en tout cas c'est
certainement pas ce genre de mesures
[Musique]
c'est ça il s'est enfui il sort en vue
devant mon dos c'est bon j'ai trouvé sa
faiblesse il n'aime pas les dos ah bah
merci pour anne d'accord il a dit c'est
par là alors fait changer d'avis plutôt
par l'ats aba voit là bas il avait bien
fait de changer la vie d'ailleurs
ok c'est la dernière fois qu'on essaye
qu'est-ce qu'il a que mon cou service
qu'il est jaloux puisque et j'ai eu mon
cou 1 parce que tu es un coup moche
ouvert en deux c'est ça y'a pas de
problème moi je ne juge pas je ne touche
pas je t'aime comme tu es à la flèche
jaune qui dit mais pourquoi il est jaune
celle ci je sais pas ce qui est ce qu a
laissé un plus gros conseil que les
flèches petit blanche à j'ai entendu un
craquement je crois qu'il est une fois
qu'il a tué quelqu'un qui est dans la
même situation que moi un peu plus loin
oh oh non oh non c'est trop dur
c'est trop dur de supporter ça on a
trouvé la sortie menant au loup trop
feige aimerait l'agencé de la procédure
j'espère que ça vous aura plu c'est le
cas ne serait pas l'aimer cela fera
vraiment plaisir ce jeu d'horreur et
hyper dur et il est très angoissant et
c'est le je pense que vous avez passé un
très mauvais moment où surtout très
belle vidéo tient tout le monde en piste
ben on joue plus d'en face en savoir
plus
[Musique]